je retrouve notre panel des ex députés
fédéraux jean pierre blackburn à
saguenay ils vont garder la voiture je
suis là comme ça à tahoua et pierre
paquette à montréal bonsoir messieurs
dames si vous le voulez bien on va
écouter un rafale c'est pas très longue
allée voir jeux 3d chef aujourd'hui sur
la question
nous sommes le 11 septembre sur la
question de la sécurité on vient d'un
prêt de 6,5 alors pour nous il est
évident que le canada peut et doit jouer
un rôle pour combattre ces terroristes
trois choses principalement que l'on
peut faire c'est de travailler fort pour
empêcher que les armes puissent se
rendre que l'argent puisse s'y rendre et
que les combattants étrangers puissent
s'y rendre si ce que les canadiens
veulent ils veulent qu'un gouvernement
protège leur sécurité tout en défendant
nos valeurs nos libertés or dans cette
situation si on a un gouvernement sous
monsieur harper qui ne croit pas qu'il
faut faire plus pour défendre nos droits
et libertés est un parti d'opposition
sous monsieur mulcair qui ne crois pas
qu'on doit faire plus pour augmenter et
protéger la sécurité des canadiens alors
premier tour de table je commence avec
vous jean pierre blackburn sur la
question de la sécurité il ya vraiment
des propositions pour les électeurs très
différentes
si on veut voter conservateur libéral
bloquiste ou npd ce black veut
effectivement comme vous savez le canada
est membre d'une coalition sous la scène
internationale on pense qu'il faut
arrêter l'état islam et qui tenteraient
de massacrer le peuple syrien
je trouve que là dessus mais monsieur
mulcair à part quand on est membre d'une
coalition ils veulent savoir les
syndicats l'appui bien moins important
que celui de solidarité en le canada est
solidaire avec les membres de la
coalition pour stopper justement l'état
islamique en solide jadis ces
extrémistes et terroristes et faire en
sorte que on redonne
paix dans ce pays et s'il y avait un
lapin en syrie mais il y aurait beaucoup
moins de populace de gens de la syrie
qui voudraient quitter leur pays
comme vous voyez présentement il ya
beaucoup de migrants d'accord et et vous
si l'état islamique poursuivait après
ils vont envahir d'autres pays
il m'a encore davantage de mika donc la
convention vous dites on est là pour 5
10 ans votre chef a dit cette semaine la
plus raide ridge c 5 10 ans peut-être
cette mission on ne peut pas le c'est
juste un ou deux faire la tâche très
bien les membres de cette coalition et
le canada et crédible sur la scène
internationale et monsieur harper a
contribué à cela mais ce godet votre
parti r on ira aux libéraux si c'est la
même chose et votre parti est votre chef
dit nous on se retire le lendemain
d'élections sur nîmes
si on est au pouvoir de cette coalition
qui entre autres bombardent les
positions de l'état islamique
regardez c'est sûr voir si on regarde de
l'épée 10 a fait a toujours été des
positions comme ça moi je me rappelle en
2001 après 11 septembre quand que le
gouvernement voulait le gouvernement
libéraux il y avait la question d'aller
en version en irak avec les états unis
le npd a fait du discours dans la
chambre je m'en rappelle très bien que
non devrait pas y aller finalement deux
tombés en afghanistan ont été postposée
d'aller en boîte de cambo ç'a commencé
en 2005 aux mondiaux en dessous de paul
martin nous autres on croit dans un pays
deux pays allaient faire la promotion de
paix et monsieur bancaire était très
claire aujourd'hui les choses qui
devraient de fait si on regarde à bachar
al assad pour un exemple il fait plus je
pense d'un mal à son pote que l'autre
est en train de faire puis lui il le
laisse tranquille en réalité est là sont
pas après lui passé de le sortir d'eux
avait raison de souligner monsieur godel
npd a une tradition pacifiste au canada
madame cops qui est pas le cas du parti
libéral évoque chef a pris une position
en disant nous on se sort également de
cette opération de bombardement est ce
que tous les libérer sont à l'aise avec
ça mais je pense que ce que monsieur
true ii a dit qu'est ce qu'on en sort du
bombardement qui a toujours été au tout
début on n'était pas supposé de faire
partie de bombardements mais on reste là
pour aider
l'opération d'aidé des militants sur
place
c'est de la différence entre notre
position messieurs moder a raison le npd
a jamais jamais appuyé aucune opération
ni de l'otan ni des nations unies ni des
coalitions et nous on pense que on n'a
pas besoin de faire partie d'une bande
de barbares de man avec le pourquoi
pourquoi mais c'est parce que le
bombardement ça devrait être les gens
les alliés de la région qui s'occupe de
faire le travail militaire et nous on
est là pour appuyer la démarche de
l'opération militaire comme les avions
va t en chambre on a va t en chambre on
peut appuyer que le canada soit là pour
entraîner les soldats mais pas pour
devenir les soldats très bien mais
pierre paquette
encore une fois notre dossier où vous
êtes tout un totalement d'accord les
libéraux là dessus mais pas totalement
d'accord parce que nous on pense qu'on
doit être présent aussi sur des lits la
ligne de front en termes de
bombardements et je pense que ce qui est
important c'est de voir chacun des cas
après les événements du 11 septembre ben
il ya une
une résolution qui a amené d'une
coalition très large une résolution de
l'onu
et on l'avait appuyé le bloc québécois
au tour de 2004 2005 c'est la question
davantage des armes de destruction
massive et on n'était pas convaincu la
démonstration de monsieur bush donc on a
voté contre cette intervention là
maintenant ici on peut pas mettre de
côté les destructions et j'irai les
atrocités sont commises par l'état
islamique et dans ce sens là on est
d'accord avec une intervention mais il
sait l'aide humanitaire qui est la force
c'est le racket c'est mon erreur je
m'excuse j'ai confondu les gens donc le
bloc québécois appuient les
bombardements et appuie le travail de la
coalition exactement mais en mettant
l'accent sur la direction sanitaire et
je devrais juste mentionné que la
position du npd comme la dernière fois
et en afghanistan est totalement
irresponsable
c'est comme si on sortirait que ce soit
de l'afghanistan où actuellement de
l'irak comme si on enlevait un qu'un
dans un camping c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que ça on a de l'équipement
d'abord on a des des militaires on a des
gens des auxiliaires qui les aide alors
c'est totalement irresponsable de penser
qu'on peut mettre fin à cette journée
québec ont dû supporter monsieur
monsieur blackburn est ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'ils jouaient je pose la
question 4 rapidement une petit
complément ce que j'avais l'impression
que les canadiens vont voter un peu en
fonction de cet enjeu là je vous dirais
fort probablement puisque vous vous
ouvrez la pop
voyez le dernier sondage ekos
aujourd'hui quelle sortie où pour la
première fois les conservateurs sont en
avance à 31 8 % pensent que la question
gens vous suivent ses 30 ans 30 à peu
près là c'est très très très serré le
dernier pour la première fois on est en
avant alors au moins c'est un mauvaise
journée pour monsieur harper parce qu on
a connu plusieurs difficile depuis le
début de la campagne et je pense la
question des migrants c'est ça les gens
veulent oui on est prêt à accueillir un
certain nombre en même temps ça doit pas
se faire au détriment de la sécurité
et ce qui reste à changer ou améliorer
ses processus et monsieur harper est en
train de travailler là dessus sur les
langues rajendra entend les trois autres
sur les migrants ya beaucoup monsieur
lagourgue beaucoup de jacquard même et
beaucoup d'ex conservateurs qui ont dit
le gouvernement canadien doit montrer un
peu plus des nerfs
j ouvrir les portes plus grand mais il y
en avait d'autres conservateurs y
compris un député un ministre de
l'intérieur qui a carrément dit que les
gens ne veulent rien savoir de ces
réfugiés là ça c'est un ministre dans le
gouvernement de monsieur harper de la
région de toronto qui a fait sept ans et
dénoncé hier alors on s'est pas
exactement c'est quoi la politique des
conservateurs parce que monsieur harper
on se trouvant dans les difficultés a
promis de sortir quelque chose mais pour
le moment on n'a rien alors qu'on voit
chez des européens en particulier
l'allemagne
ils reçoivent de 10 à 15000 personnes
par jour et nous on prétend que
peut-être on va accepter un autre de
2500 dans deux trois ans donc monsieur
de la grèce qui ont rien à faire plus
rapidement là en plein même en pleine
campagne dans les nombres l'intérieur il
y avait des jaunes d'oeuf de l'espace
pour accueillir neuf mille immigrés de
plus en provenance de la série et dans
cette campagne électorale est prêt
ministre a dit aussi je suis prêt en en
accepter dix mille de plus pour question
de remuer le problème ethnique et de
religion alors certains espaces de 19000
en termes de nombre alors ce qu'il faut
maintenant c'est comment améliorer le
processus demain alors c'est ça qu'on
attend du premier ministre et pas besoin
d'attendre
le 19 octobre pour nous dire qu'est ce
qu'il va faire c'est un problème qui
date call quelques semaines ses droits
oui mais chez son côté remis au pape de
nous dire rapidement
c'est quoi les mesures qu'il entend
faire pour assouplir les règles d'entrée
des réfugiés syriens
et s'il ne le fait pas c'est que son
obsession la sécurité fait en sorte
qu'ils considèrent que ces gens là sont
des faux réfugiés comme le même si les
ministres ontariens à un tour de table
rapide sur le film sur glace bug je
trouve malheureux c'est que tous les
ministres de l'immigration provinciaux
se sont réunis par téléphone hier
oui il ya seulement un ministre qui
n'étaient pas présentes celles du
gouvernement du canada
alors il faut il faut qu'il faut quand
même faire quelque chose et on a
l'impression qu'ils sont laides
on ne sachant pas quoi faire parce qu'il
y en a des conservateurs qui veulent les
aider pierre nadeau qui veulent pas très
bien mais j'ai vu se dresser faire une
campagne avec une campagne de peur
monsieur blackburn et là il dit que
monsieur après aujourd'hui peut se
réjouir parce que y'a montant sandales
pied des campagnes de peur c'est
toujours cette campagne de peur qu'ils
mentent il fait peur aux canadiens en
est capable d'amener les réfugiés ici
pour les capables faire ce que
sécuritairement qui en même temps faire
le processus plus vives s'est s'offert
faut bien dire les personnes en place
qui est capable de strini ces personnes
là qui les emporte et le pur et bien
c'est sûr qu'il fait c'est une campagne
de peur monsieur blackburn vous avez
dans votre cas vous avez engagé et
donnait un rôle accru 1 1
je serai d'hiroshima est-ce que c'est
donc dire que vous recopie vous l'avez
dit assez clairement tout à l'heure je
pense faux faudrait être aveugle pour
pas le voir votre parti a eu un début de
première moitié extrêmement difficile un
double album effectivement je pense
qu'on connaît tous l'histoire de filles
l'histoire des musées de grasse me
gauvin la france récession alors l'homme
maintenant le point le prévenu ça voulu
apporter du renouveau en quelque sorte
dans l'équipe pour réorienter et rallye
de gestuelle c'est correct c'est qu'avec
le prix miné ce moment donné sans qu'un
ajustement à faire
depuis il ya moins pour un temps que je
trouve que c'est ça veut dire qu'il
perçoit bien les choses c'est un homme
qui est quand même rigoureux il envoie
il veut continuer à faire en sorte de
protéger les canadiens
et continuez à axer la campagne
électorale sur l'économie mais alors
c'est plutôt celle plus tôt elle
personne c'est plutôt une personne de
des viseurs diviser le peuple et c'est
ça révisé pour règle pour rennes nice et
sochaux est plutôt derrière un
rassembleur plutôt de rassembler les
gens il est même pas capable d'avoir une
réunion au canada durant la campagne
électorale puis rouvrir les portes aux
canadiens seniors sur focus selon la
personne qui viennent de l'australie est
connue parce qu'il est le roi des
mauvaises publicités
alors en attendant les mauvaises choses
c'est pas nous c'est pas une bouchée
félicite yvon pradeille monsieur paquet
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle j'assure
vers la cloche pour les croquettes est
terminée mais j'allais vous poser la
question la semaine prochaine je vous
promets vous êtes le premier parce qu'au
bloc québécois on trouve la campagne
longue ou si on verra ce que your un
sauveur y at il quelqu'un qui peut
arriver pour changer la donne chez vous
aussi soyez pas inquiet il reste encore
suffisamment de temps pour que le vent
tourne salut on a vu un requin